en el último vídeo nos dimos cuenta que
3 elevado a la potencia menos 2 es
exactamente lo mismo que 1 entre 3
elevado al cuadrado que por cierto esto
es lo mismo que 1 entre 9 de lujo 3
elevado a la menos 2 es igual a 1 entre
3 al cuadrado que es igual a 1 entre 9 y
para esto utilizamos una propiedad nada
propiedad que conocemos muy bien de las
leyes de los exponentes que nos dicen
que si nosotros tenemos una base elevado
a una potencia y a esto lo multiplicamos
por la misma base elevada a otra
potencia entonces la base se conserva y
las potencias se suman y justo en este
vídeo lo que quiero trabajar es ver a
qué es equivalente la expresión
elevado a la menos ve tras lo que voy es
tras saber a qué es equivalente esta
expresión
quiero saber a qué es equivalente esa
expresión y para encontrar la expresión
equivalente a ésta voy a utilizar justo
la misma propiedad la misma propiedad
que decía a y vamos a ponerla por aquí
que ha elevado a la vez elevado a la vez
esto a su vez lo multiplicamos por am
por a elevado y bueno en este caso voy a
utilizar menos b elevado a la menos b
esto es exactamente lo mismo que am que
am
elevado a la suma de estas dos potencias
estás de acuerdo elevado a la vez a más
déjame poner otro color
más o menos ven más o menos ve que por
cierto esto es exactamente lo mismo que
am date cuenta que la a se conserva ha
elevado al ave más menos b lo cual es ve
- ven y esto es 0 esto es 0 y entonces
ha elevado a 0
esto por otra propiedad que nosotros no
sabemos muy bien de las leyes los
exponentes esto es exactamente igual a
uno a uno si a no es cero para todas a
que sea distinta de cero para
distinta de 0 ok y bueno esto lo estoy
poniendo así porque ahora puedo concluir
cuál es la expresión equivalente a
elevado a la menos ven de aquí si yo
utilizo esta parte de aquí me va a
quedar y lo voy a copiar y lo voy a
pegar me va a quedar que ha elevado a la
b por ha elevado la menos ven esto es
exactamente lo mismo que uno que uno y
ahora si divido todo entre a a la vez
entre ha elevado la potencia bien de
aquí voy a obtener que han elevado a la
menos ven elevado a la menos b que es
justo lo que yo quería esto va a ser
igual a 1 a 1 / / a su vez / ha elevado
a la vez /
elevado a la vez y esto para todas a que
sea distinta de cero está de lujo ya
tengo la expresión que yo quería esta
expresión de aquí va a ser mi expresión
equivalente para ha elevado a la menos b
ahora quiero que te des cuenta que este
de aquí este de aquí es el inverso
multiplicativo de aa la b porque cuando
yo multiplico estas dos expresiones me
está igual a 1 por ejemplo aquí un
noveno es el inverso multiplicativo de 9
que por cierto estrés elevado al
cuadrado y también está genial acabamos
de ver un caso particular pero justo en
este momento acabamos de decir que era
un caso general se cumple esto acabamos
de llegar a esta conclusión que es
bastante importante ya podemos ver que
cualquier base elevado en la potencia
negativa es exactamente lo mismo que 1
entre la misma base elevada a la misma
potencia solamente que con signo
positivo y bueno yo te había dejado de
tarea que pensarás un poco acerca de qué
representaba este ha elevado la menos b
y algunas propiedades de esta misma
expresión por qué porque ahorita vamos a
utilizar y vamos a ser un ejemplo para
esto voy a poner aquí no sé se me ocurre
5 a no espera
quiero cambiar de color vamos a utilizar
otros jugadores que no he utilizado como
no no quiero cambiar de color utilizando
otros colores que no he utilizado y
ahora pongamos esto si tengo 5
5 elevado al cubo bueno nosotros sabemos
cuántos esto esto es exactamente lo
mismo que 5 por 5 por 5 lo cual es 125
nosotros sabemos que 5 elevado al cubo
es 125 que por cierto es un número
bastante grande o considerablemente
grande puedo decir así ahora si nosotros
pensamos en 5 elevado a la menos tres a
menos tres cuánto es esto bueno nosotros
ya sabemos que podemos encontrar una
expresión equivalente utilizando esta
igualdad de aquí es decir que esto es
exactamente lo mismo es exactamente lo
mismo que uno que uno entre entre 5
elevado al cubo entre 5 elevado al cubo
5 elevado al cubo que por cierto esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 1 entre 5
elevado al cubo que es 125 ahora quiero
que te des cuenta de dos cosas muy
importantes 1 entre 125 es el recíproco
o el inverso multiplicativo de 125 es
decir que 5 elevado al cubo es el
recíproco o el inverso multiplicativo de
5 elevado a la menos 3 y la segunda cosa
que quiero que veas es que 125 dijimos
que era un número considerablemente
grande mientras que 1 entre 125 es un
número muy pequeño ojo cuando llevamos a
una potencia negativa obtenemos un
resultado positivo
sin embargo obtenemos un valor con una
magnitud distinta a la original y
considerablemente distinta pero bueno
aquí tenemos un ejemplo yo quiero hacer
dos ejemplos más en este vídeo porque me
gusta mucho pensar acerca de todo esto
así que para esto que te parece si
borramos la pantalla para hacer
otro ejemplo más entonces déjenme borrar
la pantalla y quiero que trabajemos con
el siguiente ejemplo aunque pasa si yo
tengo menos un medio menos un medio esto
elevado a la tercer potencia a la tercer
potencia bueno pues esto es exactamente
lo mismo que menos un medio por menos un
medio menos un medio por menos un medio
por menos un medio es decir tres veces
lo mismo o menos un medio menos un medio
es decir tres veces lo mismo lo cual por
cierto es menos por menos más por menos
menos uno por uno por uno es 1 y 2 por 2
por 2 es porque es menos un octavo es
decir que si yo me tomo menos un medio
elevado al cubo obtengo menos un octavo
lo cual es un número negativo pero un
octavo es más pequeño que un medio ahora
qué va a pasar si yo me tomo este mismo
menos un medio pero ahora lo voy a
llevar a una potencia negativa vamos a
elevarlo a la menos 3 que voy a obtener
de esto bueno pues esto es lo mismo y
utilizando lo que acabamos de aprender
en este vídeo recuerda que lo que
tenemos que hacer es poner un 1
un 1 ya esto lo voy a dividir entre esta
misma expresión solamente que elevado a
una potencia positiva es decir a 1 entre
menos un medio elevado al cubo al cubo
al cubo y por cierto nosotros ya sabemos
cuánto es menos un medio elevado al cubo
es justo lo que tenemos acá arriba por
lo tanto esta expresión que tengo aquí
esto que está acá abajo acabamos de
concluir hace ratito que era menos un
octavo entonces esto de aquí va a ser
igual a uno a uno entre menos un octavo
entre a menos un octavo que por cierto
nosotros sabemos que esto es exactamente
lo mismo que uno esté uno se conserva ya
esto en lugar de dividirlo entre una
fracción lo voy a multiplicar por el
recíproco de esta fracción nosotros
hemos hecho divisiones de versiones
muchas veces vamos a multiplicarlo por
- y el recíproco de 1 entre 8 es decir
el inverso multiplicativo es 8 entre 1
ok esto ya lo sabíamos que por cierto
esto es exactamente lo mismo que tener a
menos por más es menos 8 por 1 es 8 y
dividido entre 1 es 8 menos ocho pero lo
que sí quiero enfatizar mucho en este
vídeo es que el resultado de elevar a
una potencia negativa no está cambiando
el signo del resultado date cuenta que
aquí empezamos con una potencia positiva
y obtuvimos aquí un valor negativo
mientras que aquí empezamos con una
potencia negativa lo obtuvimos también
un resultado negativo lo que está
cambiando realmente no es el signo de
nuestro resultado sino la magnitud de
éste